jean claude van damme s'est lui
karatékas culturiste boxeur adeptes du
full contact vous donner des chiffres
avec 329 combat gagnant maintenant il
est devenu plus fort que tu partes ce
n'est guère tchèque maurice ou sylvester
stallone parce que vous êtes un
véritable sportive crois que chuck
norris aussi d'ailleurs les où il était
alors le le sport allié au cinéma
c'était une carrière que vous aviez
prévu
non c'était le cinéma d'abord mais j'ai
commencé par le sport vous avez fait
quoi vous aviez une salle de gymnastique
vous êtes entraînés pendant des années
parce que ce que l'on voit qu'il est
très facile demande une forme
extraordinaire et puis un entraînement
tous les jours j'ai commencé le karaté
la culture physique à l'âge de 11 ans et
j'avais une salle de gymnastique à
bruxelles et il faut m'excuser pour mon
français car je me moi je vous reproche
rien là jusqu'à présent le trouve que
c'est très bien ça fait 6 et ambiance
est parfait elle a fait copier vous dire
oui et vers l'âge de 20 ans j'ai décidé
de partir aux usa pour réussir dans le
cinéma américain a voulu être acteur
avant d'être sportif c'était un rêve
d'enfance à l'âge de 9 ans je rêvais
déjà d'être dans l'écran alors comment
cela se passe-t-il on vient vous
chercher
vous poussez les boutons de senet
comment faites vous pour qu'on vous
remarque dans le monde du cinéma aussi
bien en france qu aux usa
personne ne vient vous chercher il faut
construire son chemin soi-même et
c'était très dur là comment avez vous
fait vous arrivez à hollywood j'ai tout
faire j'ai tout fait j'ai travaillé sans
son permis était illégale dans le pays
quand je suis arrivé aux usa je parlais
pas anglais et j'ai contacté toutes les
personnes que je savais comme stallone
chuck norris producteurs castanet et
john directeur et finalement c'est la
can film qui m'a qui m'a accroché et
maintenant vous en êtes à votre deuxième
film 3e troisième film et j'ai signé
pour cinq ans avec différentes
compagnies alors là vous avez vous eu de
soucis là ça va bien ça va très bien
alors est ce que pour le film celui dont
on a parlé bloodsport c'est une histoire
c'est votre histoire est ce que
l'histoire est important
disons que les gens
adore quand on s'est basé sur une
histoire réelle et c'était le seul film
qui pouvait me faire démarrer aux usa
avec mes habilité dans le karaté mais je
vais m'orienter plus vers le drama que
le film d'action vous voulez être un
véritable acteur c'est ça qui sait faire
du karaté du full contact et c'est mon
prochain film
le nom s hybrid annie sortira sur les
écrans pour noël en europe
de même qu aux usa rappelez-nous votre
nom jean claude van damme on s'en
souviendra
si ce journal est à présent terminée je
vous remercie de l'avoir suivi vous avez
rendez vous ce soir 20h avec hervé
claude dans quelques instants la météo
avec sophie davant passer une bonne
journée et un bon week end
au revoir
non